so go through the list tell us what
we're going to be getting let's say in
terms of hardware the iphone well the
most will you just hold it well you
can't ask the question then no no but I
want to know what's in the iphone i mean
everyone already supposedly has an
iphone what's going to be better about
this iphone now there is a good question
the expectation at Bill Graham I
auditorium tomorrow they will be
announcing a new iphone back probably
two new iPhones to upgrade the iphone 6
and 6 plus they will announce an iphone
6s and a 6s plus or maybe a 6 plus s
these are the great mysteries we have to
deal tomorrow but one of the things
we'll expect better cameras maybe the
ability to record even more video with a
camera I a self facing or front-facing
camera as well it'll be able to record a
very high quality video maybe those are
some speculation around that iphones of
both flavors as i mentioned the 6 and
the 6 plus both improved and that's a
big deal for this company because the
iphone is come to regard to be such a
big percentage of revenues greater than
ever before whether you want to look at
on a quarterly basis or even a trailing
12-month basis the iphone and a trailing
12 months is you know look at my model
it's sixty-five percent of revenues over
the trailing 12 months so principally
this is a company again we're nearly
two-thirds of revenues come from the
sale that one product but they've
changed the way they do that either the
fiscal year right which ended September
2014 fifty-six percent of sales so think
about that they've gone just in three
quarters from fifty six percent of sales
to sixty-four percent of sales coming
from the iphones it's a big deal for
this company in part because they
changed the way a year ago the way they
unveil these products they used to
unveil them first in the US and then
spread to other geographies a year ago
when they announced at six and the six
plus they launched in the US and in
china and that led to massive
year-over-year growth but also gives
some very tough comparisons on a
year-over-year basis not least of which
because the china smartphone growth is
shrinking dramatically from about twenty
percent year-over-year to probably two
percent according to IDC so the
headwinds are great when they look into
China Corey any word on introduction of
new let's say Apple watch versions so
there's speculation that there'll be new
bands
for the Apple watch there's even a
suggestion they're going to demonstrate
a new operating system for future Apple
watches but there's very little
speculation that they will be announcing
and I want you know I don't to
pre-announce for them i want ya later
moment what about apple TV because I'm
worried that they won't get enough
coverage tomorrow yeah yeah well you'll
be handling one of that what about Apple
TV so Apple TV has not been updated
since 2012 so this product that has been
on the market now for we think of seven
years or so maybe almost eight years
very good there's speculation that
they're going to be actually updating
that product which is needed an update
perhaps and one of the big questions
will they open this up so that other
developers can put apps on of this
product principally it's been a closed
environment so the Apple decide if
they're going to launch an NBA TV or an
HBO product or so on if they open this
up for development it could be much more
interesting platform because they'll be
tapping the minds of hundreds of
thousands of developers not just those
working at apple yeah they get to right
let's say game programs for the for the
larger screen all right so that's the
big question right though if they
launched an open platform can people use
the processing power on that Apple TV
device to write games for the phone
effectively making it a competitive game
platform maybe not as good as the
processing power of the Xbox or
Playstation put something could be power
seen I was going to give you 10 seconds
to tell us who is Bill Graham because
it's being held at the bill graham
auditorium bill grant Ellis PIM go ahead
who's pila grille he was a legendary
concert promoter here in the Bay Area
did fantastic concerts whether it was
Altamont with the rolling stones or many
great Dead shows Jefferson star should
be the legend of the bay or maybe he'll
be walking over there apple announcement
tomorrow okay he's having you for
assault thanks very much